congresswoman ilan omar is calling out
some of her colleagues for getting the
coronavirus vaccine before
frontline workers the minnesota democrat
even went after
fellow squad member alexandria
ocasio-cortez who received the shot
over the weekend let's bring in former
wisconsin congressman sean duffy a fox
news contributor and robert wolf ceo of
32 advisors and former economic advisor
to president obama
so robert does she have a point when
she's looking at her fellow squad member
aoc
she pulls her shirt down she does the
whole thing so that everybody can see
her getting this shot
when we know many of our front line
workers and even our seniors
haven't even had access to the shot yet
so she definitely has a point but she
has a point personally her father passed
away
from coven so i i have to say if i was
her
i would absolutely make sure and want to
make clear that the elderly should
get covered before anyone but if i was
in congress
and where i sit today outside of
congress i actually think the 535
members
should get the vaccine and it will bring
us back to a normal environment in
committee
and from a foreign intelligence
perspective we need people back in
committee
robert or sean ilan omar says this we
are not more important than front-line
workers
teachers et cetera who are making
sacrifices every day which is why i
won't take it people who need it most
should get
it full stop tulsi gabbard agrees but
she also says
i shouldn't get it before our seniors
get it here's gabbard
now they are recommending that a hundred
million so-called
essential workers they can get the
vaccine before
our grandparents can that members of
congress like me
we can get the vaccine before at-risk
seniors
can i'd plan to take the vaccine but
we'll now
stand in solidarity with our seniors by
not
doing so until they can sean
listen i agree with omar right she's
exactly right there's so first of all
there's enough old people in the
congress
that would qualify for being elderly and
have comorbidities where they should get
the virus and i think that's an
important message to the american people
that you know what this is a safe
vaccine we can all take it you know
trump has vice president has biden has
and so are the older members of congress
but if you're young like omar or aoc
um there's no need for you to take the
vaccine give this to the older people in
america
the the congress and fauci and others
have said follow the science
well the science would dictate that the
older people should get it first
and uh these members of congress who are
younger are at lower risk of actually
dying from the virus